- Somewhere in the hills just over there
is the Chauvet cave.
It was discovered in 1994,
and inside is artwork
that's around 30,000 years old,
some of the best-preserved cave paintings
anywhere in the world.
It's a connection to ancestors
who lived tens of millennia
before history began.
Only a lucky few people
are ever allowed in that cave,
and almost all of them are scientific
researchers and conservators.
There's no way that some guy with a camera
is ever going to get in there.
...right?
- The Chauvet cave
is the oldest painted cave we know of.
The cave has been rediscovered
the 19th of December 1994.
It has been a tremendous discovery.
It has pretty much changed everything
we thought until then.
Roughly 1,000 representations,
paintings, drawings, engravings.
The engravings are white in color,
the paintings are red, and the drawings,
which are made with charcoal, are black.
- This isn't the real cave.
It's a replica called Chauvet 2.
When I say replica,
I don't just mean the art,
but the shapes of the cave walls
that it's painted on
were laser scanned and recreated.
Cavers and historians would be able
to pick up things
that give it away, like
the suspiciously well-maintained lighting,
but to a layperson,
this is roughly the experience you'd get
standing in the original Chauvet cave
if it had been turned
into a tourist attraction,
complete with a lot
of other exhibits outside.
So my question is: if you can
replicate something this accurately,
how much does it matter
that it's not the original?
- The original cave
was scanned several times,
so we've gathered a point cloud
that was made of 16 billion points.
The original Chauvet cave
takes roughly
500 meters to get from the entrance
to the end of the cave,
so it is really huge.
In the original cave,
you could walk
for five, six, seven minutes
and see nothing.
It would have been a waste
to recreate the cave as it was
because the point was
to make it more accessible,
so it has been reduced.
If there's something
that we did not change,
it's just the drawings themselves,
the representations.
They're where they're supposed to be,
you see them in the order
that you're supposed to see them
in the original cave.
If at some point
we've changed sizes of some rooms,
we did not touch the walls on which
the paintings and the drawings were made.
They're exactly in the same place
in the very same shape
as the original ones.
The walls are concrete
and for the finer details such as bones,
stalactite, stalagmite, and so on,
it is resin modelled to the shape
of the original cave.
The art is recreated by hand.
They have been made
as precisely as could humanly be possible.
To the millimeter, actually.
They did not only do it by hand,
but they did use the same,
the very same type of wood
to make the charcoal.
The paintings, the reddish paintings,
they're made of hematite,
the same type of rock that was
used by the prehistoric painters.
- Tourists aren't allowed
in the original cave
for very good reasons.
That lesson was learned at Lascaux,
another cave a few hours west of here,
that was also filled
with prehistoric art.
It was discovered in 1940,
and it was opened as a tourist attraction,
which destroyed it.
Not completely, but: the presence
of 1,000 people a day
and the changes in temperature,
and humidity, and carbon dioxide levels,
and contaminants
that all of them brought along,
well, it meant that after
tens of thousands of years of stability,
bacteria, fungi, and algae
took over the walls.
Despite desperate conservation efforts
through the 20th century,
the Lascaux cave will never ever be
what it once was.
- The prehistoric entrance
of the Chauvet cave is sealed off.
Tonnes and tonnes of rock that collapsed
right on the entrance and sealed it off.
All the people, all the animals
that got inside of the cave
during prehistoric times,
they cannot possibly
enter the cave anymore,
and it has been so
for at least 21,000 years.
The fact that the cave has been isolated
from the outside world,
it made the atmosphere very stable
which allowed the paintings
and the drawings
to be preserved the way they are.
-The trouble is,
tourists like visiting the real places.
There is something
about actually being there,
about standing exactly where
an ancestor painted on a wall,
and this cave can't provide that.
But it isn't a Disney World mock-recreation,
it's pretty accurate,
and just a few kilometers away
from the original.
The sights,
the physical sensations are close,
except you don't have to be harnessed in
and climb down a big ladder to get here.
If the original cave
had been open to tourists,
it would have been changed,
maybe devastated.
Would this feel the same
if someone built this replica
in Paris, or in London, or Sydney?
How much does the context
of the experience matter?
How important is authenticity?
I don't have the answers to any of that,
but I can say that
a few times while I've walked around here
even with the rational knowledge,
that it's not the same place,
even knowing that I will exit
through the gift shop,
For a few seconds,
a bit of my brain was fooled.
Although, maybe that's because
I got to be in here
alone after hours.
Either way, I do like one idea,
that in another 30,000 years' time,
some future archeologist
is going to be really confused
by two identical caves
next to each other.
- The huge amount of painted caves
we've discovered yet,
all the art they've left us,
it shows us that
those societies were in good health
because if they did have time
to do all of this,
it's because they had free time.
It shows they do have a life,
they do have culture,
they do have art as we do today.
They might have not done it
for the very same reason,
but they do have it.
It shows that they do not just
merely survive, they live.